going into number two did you want to
stay the same or did you want to sort of
have a different message what was the
philosophy I thought about replacing
drew - I thought about swapping him out
for something else but do you realize he
wants it to be a success yeah he's
always growing on the messaging because
we had a great messaging from builder
brothers big plans our first book about
failures not a bad thing yep because
that's the path to success if you learn
from it and so building on that with our
second book better together it's all
about working together and I think
that's something something it's not a
bad idea it's not a bad thing to have
different ideas yeah there's more than
one great idea out there but together
you can come up with it right I honestly
do think the best life lessons come from
kids books because if you if you think
about if you've read a lot of kids book
you've got obviously Roxie and and you
read these books and like it has to be
entertaining for the child visual I mean
our our artist who did all the
illustrations is amazing Kim Smith but
there also should be a message it should
be a learning experience for the
children and so every book not only is
there a great message but at the end
there's a project that the child can you
know build something with their parent
or their teacher and I love that people
learn things from your shows all the
time
adults learn things from your shows all
the time but when it comes to teaching a
kids something there's a certain amount
of pressure that comes with that when
it's like what is the thing we're going
to teach chainsaws I don't know on a
ranch we were given know I mean there
was actually there a lot of restrictions
for like children's books - you want to
have certain educational components and
I think it was a big process for us and
we have an amazing team working with us
- because we want to make sure we got it
right it has to be a fun read for the
kids yeah and then we love the fact -
that at the end you have this hands-on
project that the kids can build for this
book it's a soapbox derby car just out
of toilet paper roll and some materials
around the house but kids want to be
tactile and kids are very literal as
well so when you say something in the
book even if it's fantastical they're
very literal and so they'll look at that
so we have a child psychologist who
worked with us on the book as well to
make sure that the messaging is
something within that age group that
could be understood by the child one of
the best things - though that I love is
Chartwells who is a leader with
providing food for educational
institutions and schools across the
country we've partnered with them and so
we're actually putting builder brothers
better too
in two schools across Canada and the
kids can come in and take the book out
then they can build the projects with
parents or teachers and then the next
kids can take the books so it's really
helping you inspire more people across
the country and okay so we got to get to
Latin America we got to get to Brady
Houston we got to get to forever home
where do you want to worry what do you
were you on a good column a column a
okay so Latin America your social was
incredible from that trip yeah we have
you know what you were getting into we
can see on social media that there's a
huge response from the Latin audience we
earn over a hundred and sixty countries
but we're dug locally and it was wild
are they brothers tell me they're like
Jonathan's guy super little boys very
sexy and then my guy come in he's like I
love Jonathan I'm your voice yeah my guy
comes like it was wild we get we did
live events in in five different
countries
yeah and over a million people entered
this contest to win tickets to the shows
and it was great I mean I love seeing
that the aspirational elements of our
shows it doesn't matter what kind of
house you live in where you live there's
still something you can take away from
it yeah what do they take away because
the houses are different Reno's
different the laws are different
everything's different they may not even
have access to the type of house you
guys show in the show so what did they
gravitate towards yeah it's actually the
biggest thing we find internationally a
lot of people gravitate towards is the
use of multi-functioning pieces and how
to maximize the function of a smaller
space the interesting thing is most of
the people challenge us on open concept
they're like because in Latin America
that open concept hasn't taken hold they
they want to keep the cooking smells
where the cooking smells are and when we
started explaining to them no it's about
letting the person who's cooking be a
part of everything that's going on or
seeing the kids and and you could see
that okay that's a different way to
think about it and whatnot but it's
slowly but surely the trend will go
there a lot of people they just know for
design they know what they grew up with
they know their parents houses so down
there a lot of these houses are very
much so generational and so it's
definitely - trying to open their eyes
to see the potential of something new is
hard and forever home you guys are
working like crazy on this 31 houses on
the go right now here between Etobicoke
Mississauga and north
it's it's crazy I mean Toronto has
always been a great place to come back
to but 31 houses at one time I'm tired
yeah so tired have a break but this is I
mean it is it is a life-changing thing
that you guys are doing right and with
that sort of responsibility are you
still now in awe of how emotional the
process is for the families that you
work with for me it's it's the most
important part of our job is being able
to put ourselves into the shoes of
somebody who's likely never done this
before a massive renovation is a huge
thing and so understanding the
importance of every little decision of
making sure that we're making the best
use of their money but at the end of the
day our philosophy is that your home
should make your life easier and the
fact that we're almost at 400 episodes
of our shows that's 400 people that
we've helped I mean that is a
responsibility like no other and also
property mother's forever home these are
people who have the home it might have
been passed down from their parents or
this is where the kids were raised
there's something about the home they
love it's just not working for them it's
not functioning and so there's more
emotion in these stories as well which
really warms our hearts and when we hand
the keys over at the end I never get
tired at that moment when you see that
look on their eyes when they when they
see their home for the first time and
Brady house so this is there's I mean
there's pressure renovating a place and
then there's pressure renovating a place
we it was crazy I mean we there were
eight HGTV designers and builders yeah
all the original six Brady cast yeah
this is the largest residential project
we have ever done but it was great to
see all the Brady kids they were all
fully hands-on helping and they weren't
just showing up like like Maureen who
played Marcia she was hilarious because
she wanted to everything jackhammering
cutting sawing everything but she'd
never done any of it before so we're
like we don't want you to hurt yourself
so let's let's slow things down low and
carpool karaoke when did you guys do
this uh just over a month ago nothing a
bit ago because we karaoke all the time
karaoke before I write yes okay so you
karaoke this is something that you do so
obviously there wasn't the nerves factor
in there but you were partnered up with
the ditional Sisters yeah who are
professional singers yeah we didn't
realize that sure okay so it talked me
through that process it was
yeah here's the songs how does that work
we had a mix yeah they're pretty good
I'll tell you what the process was yes
drew cuz Drew was like super hyper
competitive and once everything to
always be perfect and he takes lessons
for everything he wanted to start
picking what key we were gonna do things
I don't even know what that means I was
told I was told we can adjust the key as
needed but I'm like but how does that
work if the girls are practicing songs
with one can then I changed the key Emma
whatever we'll see but in the end it was
amazing was fun and we did I think we
didn't like eight or nine songs and then
we just started doing our own songs off
our phones it was right some time and
the actual like doing when when you sort
of get lost in that moment where you're
just saying it and you're with friends
and you're did you have a realization of
oh god people are actually gonna watch
this yeah we were sitting there and you
do you get lost in the fun that you're
having all this stuff and then you
realize like this it's a big show and a
lot of people are obsessed with this
show and so then all sudden you're like
am I on key right are we gonna swerve
into traffic here no actually that's the
one thing I would say so you actually
driving yeah yeah Zoe was driving but
the funny thing is we kept getting a
song and because you know we were
there's a follow car like we're supposed
to follow card and you know the path
that we're going police are going yeah
the police are like with us in front
anyway we're driving on your she keeps
driving off in the wrong direction as
they all do she's singing like this and
then she's going I'm like we wish and
then all sudden the police had to come
around and like get us again and follow
it it was fun I mean when you watch
James Corden when he when he does it
yeah he has so much fun so for years and
we've been saying we got to go on the
show it's so up our alley that is
amazing and that what else do you guys
want to do so when when forever home is
done all this stuff what is this sort of
next step to sleep sleep there is sleep
know the one thing we do love is live I
mean as you know we come from a
background where we used to do comedy
and stand up wheel of a live audience we
used to theatre and so even for our kids
book to be able to go around and see our
fans on our book tour in person read to
the kids it's hilarious when you're
reading the books the kid is seeing
their reactions and then to build the
project that's the kind of thing we love
to do
you